Joe Biden is in trouble and he knows it
the writing has been on the wall for a
while the record inflation the Dismal
growth the open border the drugs the
crime we all can sense that the country
is in free fall but now we know it for
sure because Joe Biden has done what
Democrats always do when things look
bleakest
he's pulled out James Taylor to play a
random ditty for reporters
[Music]
just yesterday morning they let me know
you're gone
Suzanne plans he made footing into you
at Joe Biden's press conference on the
preposterously titled inflation
reduction act which does not reduce
inflation it actually increases
inflation the president opened the
questions
with the same aging hippie that his
party trotted out back in 2015 after the
Obama administration had caused an
international Scandal by offending the
French
foreign
[Music]
when people can be so cold
they'll
[Music]
take your soul if you let them
don't you let them
why do they keep doing this
why James Taylor I it's so weird
I actually like James Taylor but well
it's so weird and no Boomer folk singer
no matter how talented can paper over a
national or International political
crisis in many ways this is the perfect
metaphor for the entire Democrat Party
the libs just never got over the 60s
they never got over the 60s back in the
60s the libs thought they were on the
brink of Utopia the cultural revolution
was going to usher in the sunny days of
the age of Aquarius and it just didn't
happen
their schemes all failed
the 60s did not Usher in Utopia
the 60s just gave us the 70s crime drugs
family breakdown and energy crisis a
stagnant economy and runaway inflation
sound familiar
but the libs stuck to their guns and now
they are proving a maxim of that OG
Pinko himself Karl Marx history repeats
itself first is tragedy now is farce I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday's from Margaret Butler
who says how can the Border be secure
and broken at the same time Kamala
Harris makes no sense yes this is what
they do they say the border is very
secure
and it's totally broken and we need to
fix it and they can do that because what
they're saying is the border is secure
for the purposes of us doing our job
but the border is in crisis for the
purposes of us getting Republicans to
give us more of what we want it's it's
actually the same logic that John
Roberts used when he heard the Obamacare
case
the Obama Obamacare opposed A difficulty
for the libs at the Supreme Court
because if the Obama if Obama Care
presented a penalty for not buying the
insurance then it was unconstitutional
but if the Obamacare if Obamacare was
just a tax then the court didn't have
the right to hear the case yet because
the tax hadn't gone into effect because
the way Obamacare was built was that you
got all the goodies the government spent
the money but 10 years before the tax
went into effect so that there wasn't
too much political pressure to kill the
bill so all of that is as background the
Supreme Court was between a rock and a
hard place what did they do they said
okay the Obamacare is a penalty for the
purposes of hearing the case but it's a
tax for the purposes of deciding the
case and that's that's what the lives do
too they just move those goal posts
Every Which Way whichever way is
convenient to them at the moment
speaking of goal posts speaking of big
edifices that can catch lots of things
like footballs and the like did you know
that your internet service provider is
catching all the data you send through
it that's why you need to check out
expressvpn right now head on over to
expressvpn.com Knowles going online
without expressvpn is like changing
while leaving your window wide open you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy when you go online without
a VPN isps internet service providers
can see every single website that you
visit
they can legally sell this information
without your consent to ad companies and
Tech Giants who then use your data to
Target you that is why I always use
expressvpn when you use expressvpn isps
cannot see that online activity your
identity is anonymized by a secure VPN
server your data are also encrypted for
maximum protection
works on phones laptops even routers
so everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can be
protected it's super easy to use I'm
pretty much a Luddite I love expressvpn
you just click the button boom you're
done it's really really easy secure your
online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com Knowles today
expresvpn.com Knowles you can get an
extra three months for free
expressvpn.com
Knowles what a sad
press conference to try to defend this
stupid bill that that obviously isn't
working
and it wasn't just James Taylor that
made it ridiculous it actually only
occurs to me now what is James Taylor's
nickname James Taylor's nickname one of
his most famous songs
Sweet Baby James good night you
Moonlight ladies Rockabye Sweet Baby
James is he telling us something have
the libs been wrong this whole time is
James Taylor
a secret conservative is he a Matt Walsh
fan I don't know
I don't know either way it wasn't the
most ridiculous part of the press
conference the most ridiculous and
hilarious part of the press conference
is when Joe Biden
was celebrating the inflation reduction
act as the stock market tumbled
this couldn't have happened without
every single one of you and that's it
it's still dropping because the other
team didn't want to play
and all our distinguished guests CEOs
act Advocates activists thank you for
joining us and what a great day exactly
four weeks ago today I signed the
inflation reduction act in the law what
a great day the the stock market's down
to four percent the stock market is in
free fall right now I just signed the
inflation reduction act very very
awkward when Joe Biden is attempting to
celebrate his economic Bill his big
economic Bill to save the economy uh
while you're on the very same screen can
watch the economy in free fall you say
well Joe I I'm hearing your words but
with my own eyes I'm seeing it isn't
working the numbers don't lie Joe Biden
does lie the White House does lie but
the numbers don't lie
the the bill is not going to to do
anything about inflation if it does
anything it's going to make inflation
worse that's not just a republican
talking point even Bernie Sanders said
that at the time that the bill was being
debated it's not going to do anything
about that it's not helping the economy
the the economy continues to collapse
and so what can the the White House do
all the White House can do is lie and
they're not just lying about the economy
or inflation or jobs or whatever they're
they're lying about virtually every
issue look at the southern border a
pretty much completely unrelated issue
but another major crisis under Joe Biden
we've got the largest number of foreign
people for illegal foreign Nationals
coming across that border over 2 million
this year it's going to be and so what
is Korean jump here the White House
Press Secretary do she says no no no
that's that's not happening
compare that to the Trump Administration
which largely just tried to build a wall
an ineffective wall along the border and
couldn't even finish that in four years
were certainly doing a lot more to
secure the border and could be doing
even more if Republicans would stop
their obstruction
so the story now from the White House is
the the White House wants to stop
illegal immigration it's just the
Republicans won't let them
the Republic you'll recall the
Republicans come into office led by
Trump in 2016 on a platform that was in
many ways centered around building the
wall and stopping illegal immigration
the Republicans succeeded at doing that
for the first months of the Trump
presidency
and you saw illegal immigration numbers
plummet but then the Democrats kept
throwing all of these impediments
screamed their heads off to stop him
from building the wall and then the
numbers started to go back up because
they obstructed Trump the whole time and
then Biden comes in he he
gets rid of what little law enforcement
Trump had instituted at the border and
then the numbers what do you expect the
numbers go straight back up
and now that's a big problem and it's
deeply unpopular so what's the White
House doing they're not changing the
policy at all they're they're just lying
about it and they they think that we're
going to buy it it actually this
demonstrates that same principle at the
top of the show
it's the same kind of language they used
with the Border back when when Trump
tried to build the wall they said walls
don't work and they're extremely cruel
and inhumane
they said well which is it if the wall
if the wall doesn't work then it's not
cruel and inhumane it's not stopping
anybody from doing anything if the wall
is extremely cruel and inhumane and it's
preventing these poor people from
Crossing into our country then obviously
the walls work which isn't well they say
it's it's either one either of these two
contradictory ideas
according to the political convenience
of Democrats
so that's all they can do they can just
lie and if the lies don't work and I
don't think people are really going to
be convinced by this people know
that we've got illegal aliens pouring
into the country you now have people in
blue cities admitting this because the
red State governors in Arizona and Texas
are bussing a very small percentage of
the illegal aliens Crossing into the
country busing them to DC and New York
and Chicago and all the blue State
Mayors who are in Blue City Mayors who
had previously said oh we're Sanctuary
cities please welcome welcome those
people diversity is our strength no
human is illegal now the minute that the
illegal aliens actually show up they're
saying this is horrible it's a strain
honor of resources stop doing it please
stop so people know that's happening no
matter what the White House is saying
people know that the economy is
collapsing they know it because they've
got retirement plans they know it
because they got their money in the
stock market even if they don't have a
retirement plan or money in the stock
market they know it because they have to
fill up their cars they know it because
they have to go to the grocery store and
they see that the prices are at 40-year
highs okay so when the lies don't work
then the libs are left with only one
option and it's one option that you are
seeing them exercise more and more
vociferously in recent weeks and that
option is to threaten people and you're
seeing that now from Tim Ryan he's
running for Senate in Ohio he's saying
not only do we need to stop these
Republicans from getting elected
not only do we need to expose their
lives not only even do we need to
investigate the Republicans he's saying
that Democrats need to kill
Maga voters we they need to kill the
Maga movement
Tim Ryan Democrat not just a Democrat
candidate for a senate but the Democrat
nominee
it is
calling to kill us
how do we fix all of these broken
systems some of those answers will come
from Republicans it's not not the
extremists that we're dealing with every
single day we've got to kill and
confront that movement
um but that you know working with normal
mainstream Republicans I think that's
going to be really really important
because we have to reform uh these
systems do we need to kill
the and now notice what he says he says
not the mainstream Republicans I'm just
talking about the Maga Republicans
but this is a ridiculous rhetorical
trick because statistically all
Republicans are Mega Republicans Donald
Trump got elected president at least at
least once
he was the Republican nominee for
president twice and very likely will be
again he is leading in the polls by a
huge margin right now the never Trump
movement is pretty much just like five
guys who meet for lunch at Bill
Bristol's house at this point
so the the
not only the mainstream Republicans but
pretty much every Republican is a Maga
Republican
and what the Democrats are saying is we
want to not only oppose
the the Republicans namely half the
country we want to do violence to them
they're terrorists they're like Al Qaeda
they're an extreme existential threat to
our sacred democracy we want to kill
them we want to we want to kill you
that's what that's what they're telling
us
and they're trying to give themselves a
little out by pretending there's some
other giant group of anti-trump
Republicans but that that doesn't exist
that's completely fake
what they're saying is we want to kill
you half the country
and and it's not just Tim Ryan
it's all these people who are comparing
us to terrorists and calling us fascists
and saying that our very existence poses
a threat to the country
it's it's Joe Biden it's Hillary Clinton
it's Kamala Harris
it's the people on CNN it's Dino badaya
it's all these other people
now speaking of violence
there's a video that's gone viral right
now
and it's a video from some school where
kids some kids are beating up another
kid and the kid there's one kid in
particular who's beating up one other
kid in particular and then there's a
group of kids standing around one of
whom is filming and in the video the kid
who the kid beating up the other kid is
black the kid getting beaten up is white
and the kids all standing around and
filming all seem to be black as well
it's a horrible horrible video but it is
basically everywhere on the internet
right now
you see the kid
throws the poor kid's head into a wall
it's now grabbing his neck he walks up
kicks him in the face I mean just Savage
absolute animal kind of behavior
and it's all you know the kid the kid
who's
the kid who's doing the beating
is is bad enough Savage enough
in a way the kid who's filming it is
even worse
maybe the kid who's doing the beating is
just like some rabid dog who can't
control his own emotions but the kid
who's doing the filming is is clearly
much more methodical about it has
thought this thing out and it's just
awful your heart breaks for this poor
little kid who's who's been beaten up
I hope the kid is okay obviously we can
all pray for the poor little kid who was
beaten up and we can hope that Justice
is done for the Savages who are who are
committing the crime the reason I bring
it up though
the reason I bring up specifically the
racial terms is we all know for a fact
that if if the races were reversed Not
only would this
be spoken of on all of the news networks
this wouldn't just be going viral on the
internet this would be on every News
Network the president would speak about
it there would be a national month of
mourning there would be riots in the
streets there there might be a
presidential address there might be a
presidential address about how we need
to have a national conversation about
race and right we all know
that that would happen and and the
reason I bring this up again is not
to point out the hypocrisy and so you
know if the roles were reversed right
that that's that's actually not my point
here
because
could you imagine if the roles were
reversed is how conservatism is going to
die because it's just of course it's
hypocritical the left knows that they
don't care that's yes uh-huh you're not
you're not telling them anything they
don't already know
the reason I mention it the reason I
even show that awful clip is because
of the strength of narrative because if
if the roles were reversed it's not just
the libs who would cynically exploit it
in the way that they're ignoring this
clip
you would feel it too
you conservative people
you conservative people all throughout
the country see the shining sea in every
city and every state of every race of
every demographic group you would feel
it a little bit too
such is the power of narrative this is
how there were plenty of
people who were kind of center-right
friends I know who would call themselves
conservatives
who started to get sucked into the
George Floyd stuff who posted the BLM
black Square
who fall into this because it is the
narrative that is drilled into us
everywhere from every cultural
institution and from the government and
in our education system and in the media
and just everywhere
and so we might know yes statistically
this isn't real statistically
racist cops chasing down black men it
just doesn't exist it's lock that one
away with Bigfoot it's totally not real
we know we we know that on an
intellectual level but such is the power
of narrative
even the centrists
even the
center right even some conservatives
would feel that instinctively
mentioning uh BLM
mentioning George Floyd and racial
politics there was a great really
incisive commentary
from Sophie corkaran who's British she's
on gbtv a conservative channel in Great
Britain
she said quote Dear Americans who mock
us for mourning our beloved Queen She
dedicated her entire life to her Duty
and our country even just two days
before her death you more into man who
pointed a gun at a pregnant woman by
burning cities to the ground we are not
the same
harsh but fair
what she's saying is you're all laughing
at us because you think it is ridiculous
that we hold the queen sacred
you hold criminals as sacred
you think it's ridiculous that we have
all this Pomp and Circumstance for her
royal Majesty the queen you had Pomp and
Circumstance you had you had four
funerals that one of which was attended
by the soon to be President Joe Biden
for a criminal who resisted arrest and
died of some combination of police force
possibly of police force and a fentanyl
overdose because he had he had a toxic
level of drugs in his system
which is more ridiculous
you you think that we've got this kind
of crazy
sacred thing that we venerate and we pay
respect to
well you've got them to you're just not
aware of it and yours are much more
ridiculous
this is actually why I'm I'm uh
cautiously hopeful about King Charles
III Charles has been an object of
derision for many years by conservatives
because he says all sorts of kooky weird
environmentalist stuff and he Pals
around with Klaus schfob and he talks
about the great reset and there are
plenty of red flags and warning signs
I'm not denying that but there was a
video that went around
it was making the rounds after Queen
Elizabeth died and it made me wonder
is Charles a little bit more
conservative than we all think it's
Charles describing
tradition the teachings of the tradition
is should not in any sense be taken to
mean that they seek as it were to repeat
the past or indeed simply to draw a
distinction between the present and the
post
theirs is not
a Nostalgia for the past but a yearning
for the sacred and if they defend the
past it is because in the pre-modern
world all civilizations were marked by
the presence of the sacred
as I understand this uh in referring to
tradition they refer to a metaphysical
reality
and to underlying principles that are
timeless
as true now as they have ever been and
will be
absolutely brilliant and and evidence
that this guy this kind of weird lib
sounding guy who rattles on about global
warming and Pals around the world
economic forum
this guy gets conservatism better than
probably 70 percent of American
conservatives or more
because he's saying and certainly better
than all the libs do he's saying
traditionalism you know conservatism is
not about a Nostalgia for the past
Nostalgia is history after a few drinks
okay when when we make an idol out of
the past we're we're really being
saccharine and sentimental the past was
not nearly as great as we all like to
imagine we sometimes think that our
childhood was the greatest period in all
of human history we think that because
we were little kids and we didn't have
any responsibilities and we had the
comfort and of our parents and and so no
it's not just about this nostalgic
hearing for the past
it is a longing for the sacred
it's a longing not for Dusty old things
it's a longing for things that are
timeless
that are ageless ideals that the
tradition is not some dusty old thing
it's it's the most vibrant thing in the
world because it's that which has
endured through so many years and
decades and centuries in Millennia even
into the present
that it's those truths and institutions
that the libs are attacking and trying
to destroy it's those sacred things
that they are desecrating
and and and and that is what keeps
conservatives up at night
and when you have those sorts of worries
probably want to talk about it with
people that's why you got to check out
pure talk okay we've got the Pure Talk
voice mailbag coming up on Friday it's
very simple the way that you submit the
question
you record a question on your phone just
on the audio app on your phone or maybe
on your computer however you record
audio keep it to 60 seconds or less if
you don't mind so I can actually feature
it on the show then you go to the
Michael Knowles show page over on The
Daily wire you click at the page you
click on the submit a mailbag question
and you just attach the file to the
email send it in and then we'll get to
hear from you on Friday and it will be a
great deal of fun
the libs
want to attack the sacred that's what
it's all about
because for the libs
at least when they begin their
Revolution nothing is sacred all the
holy taboos that we have
they desecrate you think one of the most
famous pieces of lib art in recent
decades was something called Piss Christ
and it was a a photograph funded by the
National Endowment for the Arts I
believe funded with your taxpayer
dollars a photograph of a crucifix in a
jar of piss
and he called it piss Christ
obviously
completely worthless as a matter of Art
but it was it was part of a political
movement and the political movement is
to take everything that we hold sacred
and destroy it
the family we we hold the family sacred
they're going to destroy that
the Bible we hold the Bible to be sacred
yeah that's going to be banned from
public schools you can't teach that you
can teach mineconf you can teach
genderqueer you can have gay porn in
Middle Schools no Bible you can't teach
that because you hold that sacred and
the lips want to destroy that
whatever your your very Nation your very
country you you you hold your country to
some degree sacred yeah we're going to
get rid of those borders absolutely
we're gonna we're gonna ship your
industry overseas we're going to import
millions of foreigners a year that's
gone absolutely not yes and especially
in the question of sex which is so
important to Human Nature
anything you hold sacred about sex the
idea of monogamy the idea of Chastity
the idea of I don't know not having like
weird deviants in the street marching
around in in leather girdles and things
you know up and down Main Street while
your kids watch the the idea of not
having uh transvestites jiggle around
for little kids at the library what in
just any in any way that sex might be
held to be something that we take care
of that we hold sacred no that has to be
destroyed and it has to be destroyed for
younger and younger audiences not just
for adults but for teenagers not just
for teenagers for little little kids
they have to do that and then what's the
consequence of that
the consequence is not that nothing is
held sacred the consequence is that they
hold new things sacred destructive
things
we once held innocence to be sacred now
we hold criminality to be sacred we've
got those poor criminals those poor
beleaguered criminals we need to let
them out of prison John fetterman who is
who is running for Senate in
Pennsylvania he says if he had a magic
wand the first thing he would do would
be to let murderers out of prison
this actually brings us to Dr Oz because
I hate this Senate race in Pennsylvania
I hate it
the Democrat is a radical socialist with
actual brain damage I don't I don't say
that to be funny the guy had a stroke
and he refuses to go into rehab for it
because he's on the campaign Trail he
wants to win and he can't string a
sentence together and he's obviously in
terrible terrible health and he's when
he was in relatively Better Health he
was a radical socialist he he's never
held an honest job in his life he's just
lived off his parents allowance which
was up to over fifty thousand dollars at
one point a year
so terrible terrible candidate
and then the Republican candidate
is Dr Oz the Republican candidate is
pretty much a Democrat who I'm not even
convinced lives in Pennsylvania he was
just a glib TV host sort of quack and
the most prominent political statements
he's made in recent years were attacking
pro-lifers and and now actively
campaigning for enshrining gay marriage
so-called radical redefinition of
marriage into law Dr Oz just tweeted Out
quote I'm proud to join this effort with
fellow Republicans I believe that
same-sex couples should have the freedom
to get married as straight couples
the same Freedom okay first of all
homosexuals or people with any kind of
unusual sexual desire have always had
the freedom and the right to get married
always for all of human history because
marriage intrinsically involves sexual
difference
two men cannot get married to one
another because that isn't what marriage
is and it never can be what marriage is
if marriage is to have any meaning at
all it must involve sexual difference
or else there is no way of
distinguishing marriage from any other
social Bond
then it just becomes a kind of financial
partnership
it's no different than starting a small
business again then it becomes sort of
like an LLC okay there's
if marriage is not the union of a man
and a woman in perpetuity
for the sake of the generation and
education of children then I just I just
don't know what marriage is then there's
no way really of defining it
my issue here is not that Dr Oz who's in
a kind of purple state who's obviously a
squish it's not even that he's he's
squishing on an issue
it's not even that he's squishing on an
issue as important as fundamental as
marriage which is the fundamental
building block of society
it's that he he's not even passively
supporting it he's not even just keeping
his mouth shut
he is actively campaigning to enshrine
into into law federal law
one of the most radical decisions if not
the single most radical decision
ever handed down by the Supreme Court
he's actively doing that
I I have no evidence that Dr Oz is even
vaguely slightly
in any way a conservative on any issue
all I know about him is that he makes
fun of pro-lifers and attacks people for
passing pro-life laws and that he holds
and he holds a view of marriage that is
so radical it would be too radical for
Barack Obama in 2010. it would be too
radical for Hillary Clinton around the
same time
that's all I know about him and so I
think what's the point of electing him
now I know the point I know the point
I know I suggested this yesterday and
everyone yelled at me but I think it's
because they didn't read what I said
closely enough I said if I were in
Pennsylvania I would strongly consider
staying home
when it comes to Dr Oz
sure vote vote for the other Republicans
but when it comes to Dr Oz I would
strongly consider not voting for him
I didn't say I wouldn't vote for him I'm
saying I would strongly consider it
because this guy is such a loser he's
such a Democrat loser it's pathetic it's
so and the god he's running a terrible
campaign he's wrong on some of the most
important issues he just is terrible
he's just an awful candidate and I keep
trying to get myself to say hey well
here's the bright side here's one he's
got nothing the guy's a complete buffoon
loser
but what's the alternative the
alternative is John Federman now
if the Republicans were going to hold
the Senate let's say we had been in
control we were going to hold the senate
or we had a we had a good electoral map
and it looked like we were going to win
the Senate with a healthy margin I would
say
okay
lose the senate seat in Pennsylvania
that's what I would say I would say if
we were gonna if we were gonna have 53
47 Republicans we had plenty of safe
seats and it was the difference between
5347 and 5248 in the Senate I'd say lose
the senate seat in Pennsylvania
the guy one look conservatives are
either social conservatives or they're
not conservatives at all I was at the
national conservatism conference
yesterday father Benedict Kelly made a
that very important point
and even in the purple States at least
keep your mouth shut on these issues at
least kind of go soft don't don't
actively campaign in this radical way
okay fine but I know I know look
Pennsylvania could be could be
the deciding factor
and John fetterman is particularly
radical
and Pennsylvania could be the deciding
factor
so I guess
I guess I guess people should vote for
Dr Oz I guess he's just such a loser
it's not even you know I just called him
a buffoon it's not even that he's a
buffoon
it's it's worse than that he's probably
too intelligent to be a buffoon
he's just a big lib he's just a big
squish lib running a terrible campaign
as a radical leftist Democrat Circa
2014.
and it's just so pathetic and I think oh
that's what the conservatives are
whatever give it to the Democrats
if you're if you're telling me I can get
a Democrat who is
700 more radical than they were seven
years ago or 650 percent more radical
than they were seven years ago okay give
me the Democrat I don't care I want a
choice not an echo and Dr Oz is nothing
but an echo all of that said all of that
said Pennsylvania could be the deciding
factor between
Republicans having the Senate Or
democrats having the Senate
and the Republicans having the Senate
could be the deciding factor in stopping
Joe Biden's Supreme Court nominees we've
got some older conservative justices on
the court
and so as a matter of just sheer
resignation
I guess if I if look you're for those
listening in Pennsylvania you got to
vote how you want to vote I guess if I
were in Pennsylvania
I would
I guess I would lean toward voting for
Dr Oz
but he's just such a loser I don't
expect him to win maybe he'll win maybe
he'll pull it out because fetterman is
such a terrible candidate and because
Joe Biden is so deeply unpopular because
things are going so horribly but you
know what I would like though here's
what I would ask if I were a voter in
Pennsylvania and I were talking to Dr Oz
I would say hey Dr Oz can you give me
any even slight hint of a suggestion
that you even would be the Swing Vote to
the Republicans I'm not even convinced
you'd be that I'm not even convinced if
it really came down to it you had to be
the deciding vote that you wouldn't just
Squish and vote with the Dems on the
important issues on holding up the
Supreme Court nominees on any issue so
can you just give me
just don't make me look like such an
idiot
voting for you could you just give me
anything man I don't know that he can
it's that it's so pathetic he's my he's
my least favorite Republican running in
this it's so sad
so and there weren't great options
General I thought I liked Kathy Barnett
there weren't generally
it wasn't one of these huge Fields where
you could but it's like why do you have
to
why do you have to run as an activist
leftist Democrat good grief
it all depends on it all depends on the
map luckily we're getting some good news
out of Georgia that the Republicans
might might be able to avoid grabbing
defeat from the jaws of Victory as they
so often do
speaking of victory
if you've been thinking to yourself hey
you know it's it's been well actually
before I get to Candace Owens thinking
of Victory uh I don't know if you've
been following the fantasy football
draft at the daily wire
I
happen to be the football King my team
is called team Nostradamus and I am
really pleased to say that my predictive
Powers my powers of of near prophecy
they stretch not only from into the
realm of politics
they also go into the realm of sports I
am winning I am beating all the craning
company guys I'm beating Matt I'm
beating Drew I'm beating Ben
I'm beating Bickley
I'm beating everybody okay I am a
football Maven and I think you could
probably tell that from my build
you know and and uh you could probably
tell that from my just sheer
sort of adonis-like athleticism but uh
follow you know follow the fantasy
football I've never watched a complete
NFL game
but I I am going to win that golden
tumbler also if you've been if you've
been wondering
Hey where's Candace Owens well I got
great news for you Candace Owens is back
from maternity leave in a brand new
daily wire Plus show
Candace Owens she is fearlessly
exploring topics that the media won't
touch and exposing the corruption and
hypocrisy in news and politics and the
best part is it's five days a week
Monday through Friday you will not want
to miss her explosive first episode
which premiered this week on daily wire
plus trust me when I say this is huge
watch Candace owens's new show now on
daily wire Plus or listen on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts
good news out of Georgia after all this
just I'm just gonna bang my head against
a wall looking at Dr Oz and the
ridiculous race in Pennsylvania
how do you lose to fetterman I don't
know it's not looking great though
there's some good news though in Georgia
Herschel Walker is doing very very well
he's gaining speed in the Georgia Senate
race
over Rafael Warnock who is a much
stronger candidate by the way the
Democrat he also is a socialist he's a
radical uh and uh he he is much better
on the campaign Trail obviously than
John fetterman is uh but Herschel Walker
is gaining a ton of ground here
according to a poll conducted by Insider
advantage in Fox 5 Warnock has lost four
points
since July uh Herschel has picked up two
points so that means that Herschel is
now leading Warnock 47-44
now do I love those numbers no
4744 means it's still anybody's race but
the momentum is clearly with Herschel
Walker
and the momentum is not with Raphael
Warnock
even though Warnock is a much better
candidate then then John fetterman for
instance in Pennsylvania how's Herschel
Walker doing it
well I think one of the ways he's doing
it is he's not sucking up to the libs on
every issue Dr Oz this show I'm going to
retitle this show Dr Oz stop blowing it
why why why
you know what Herschel Walker is doing
he's being normal he's just being a
normal guy one of the knocks against
Herschel Walkers candidacy was Herschel
Walker he doesn't know a lot about
politics he's not some Egghead you know
sort of policy wonk he is just a very
famous athlete
yeah he's a very famous athlete who is
seems pretty solid on the issues I
haven't sat down with Herschel Walker at
length but he seems like he's pretty
solid good old Conservative candidate
and he's normal
okay and this is something that the
Republicans are going to have to think
about when we look ahead to 2024 because
the people who are paying attention
right now to the 2024 horse race
or the people who are listening to this
show are the people who are reading up
on the political reports or the people
who know exactly what's going on in the
economy and criminal justice and and
immigration and that is unusual okay I'm
not saying that to flatter you the
people who are listening to this show
your very high information voters
I'm and I'm not saying it no way to say
I'm just giving you all this truth
though obviously I am I I just mean if
you pay attention really at all to
politics especially in off years you
just are a high information voter okay
and
a lot of people maybe most people are
not they're doing other things and so
when we're looking for candidates
it's it's really good to get candidates
who are normal
okay this is one advantage that Donald
Trump has is he normal in the sense that
he's just like your average Joe on the
street no of course not in many ways
Donald Trump is extremely unusual he was
born very very wealthy he's been a major
International Celebrity for 40 years he
flies around on a gigantic airplane and
sleeps with supermodels and you know no
it's but the way he approaches politics
is pretty normal okay
and he talks to people in a normal way
and that I think is what we've got to
focus on
with sometimes you get political
candidates like Dr Oz who are just
spending all their time sucking up to
Beltway Democrat people who really don't
represent America there's a huge Chasm
between the liberal Elite right now and
ordinary Americans and the Democrats
know that that's why the Democrats are
lying and threatening ordinary Americans
and calling us an existential threat to
the country
so it's if you have to choose that
you're you're running for office
would you choose to side with the
extremely out of touch and unpopular
liberal Elite or would you choose to
side with ordinary people
that's that's a no-brainer I guess
unless you're Dr Oz so that's one way
that the Republican candidates stop
being normal you get someone like ASA
Hutchinson is the governor of of
Arkansas
and he refuses to sign a bill that will
prevent quacks from transiting little
kids not even stopping transgender
surgery generally just transiting the
little kids he goes no no that's far
that's far too far that's right because
he he is just beholden to Liberal Elite
consensus which is completely detached
from Ordinary People
that's one way they do it then the other
way they do it that conservatives get
really really weird is they get super
ideological and they say well actually
you know uh here's my five bullet point
plan for how I'm gonna just uh
completely remake all of the public
policy in America to have my ideal I
don't know capitalist Utopia or this or
that or this and it's it's just like
really strange and when they get
extremely beholden to ideological
platitudes that turns people off too
this is why it was my favorite line from
Trump in 2016. when they had and it was
the one that irritated all of the
Egghead For Eyes conservatives
is when he Trump was asked hey what what
do you want to do as president what's
your number one priority he says I want
people to have good communities you know
I want people to have good neighborhoods
be safe you know do well have the
economy be strong
I want them to have like a good life you
know
and then all the ideological Eggheads he
said that's actually not the role of the
president to give people a good life no
that's not that's a violation of
federalism and blah blah blah blah blah
no man are you that's politics 101.
yeah I'm hey I'm running to make your
life better what's my ideology uh I want
I want more good and less bad how about
that
yeah that's how normal people think it's
not how the Beltway thinks that's how
normal people think do that and frankly
in many ways I think that's how Herschel
Walker is campaigning
speaking of weird moves from senators
and Senate candidates
Lindsey Graham Lindsey Graham has just
introduced a bill
at the federal level obviously to ban
abortions Nationwide
after 15 weeks the bill is called the
protecting pain-capable unborn children
from late term abortions act and he
announced it during a press conference
okay
in principle
I like this
I don't love this because I don't want
to ban abortions after 15 weeks I just
want to ban abortion because a person's
person no matter how small and we
shouldn't be able to kill any babies so
but in principle I guess I like it I I'd
rather it be harder to
rather be harder to get abortions than
easier and so if this bill makes it
harder okay that's fine
but practically speaking I don't get it
at all there is a zero percent chance
that this bill will go into effect the
Democrats have the house the Democrats
have the Senate and the Democrats have
the presidency there is a zero percent
chance of spill goes into effect
furthermore the Supreme Court says this
abortion is not a federal issue it's
going to be a state's issue now you you
might believe it could be a federal
issue I think there's a strong argument
that it could be a federal issue but
no branch of government currently will
even entertain this
so all this could possibly do
is
bring the issue bring the abortion issue
to the Forefront in the midterm
elections I don't know that there's any
reason to do that the the abortion issue
motivates Democrats to get out to the
polls it may even motivate Republicans
more but still why would you take that
risk when you've got great issues like
the economy when you've got great issues
like immigration when you've got great
issues like foreign policy when you've
got when Biden is I say they're great
issues because Biden is failing on all
of those issues why wouldn't you make
that the issue why would you get to
bring up this really controversial
matter that though extremely important
and and a central issue
cannot possibly go into effect why
wouldn't you wait until after the
midterms when when Republicans win back
the house and very possibly win back the
Senate though it's close why wouldn't
you wait until then to bring this up and
we have at least a chance of kind of
getting it some Headway
why and I I I'm scratching my head on
this all this can possibly do is make it
harder for Republicans to win the Senate
why
and then it hit me I have a theory I'm
not totally sold on this Theory it's
just something that popped into my head
I'm working it out in real time I would
love to hear your thoughts
is Lindsey Graham introducing this bill
he's obviously not introducing him
because he thinks it's going to pass it
can't possibly pass
and he's a relatively intelligent man I
don't I don't think that he is under any
Illusions about that
is he introducing this bill
because he doesn't want Republicans to
win the Senate hear me out
why would Lindsey Graham why would the
sort of establishmentarian Republicans
why would they want to win the Senate
right now
well okay you can stop some of Joe
Biden's agenda though some of it I'm not
sure you can even stop all that much
maybe you can stop some of the judges
that would be good
but what's the downside the Republicans
almost certainly are going to win the
house if Republicans don't win the house
we don't have a serious electoral system
it's all fraud so let's say Republicans
win the house
there's going to be huge pressure for
the Republicans to impeach Joe Biden
because the Democrats now just use the
tool of impeachment
as a political cudgel there's there's
really no legal basis anymore they
impeach Trump twice over over complete
nonsense so
there's gonna be a huge amount of
pressure to retaliate and impeach Joe
Biden I suspect the house will do that
then it's going to be up to the Senate
to convict remember Donald Trump was
impeached twice but he was never
convicted because the Republican Senate
never convicted him
if Republicans control both have both
houses there will be a huge amount of
political pressure not only to impeach
but to convict
and I think most Republicans do not want
to convict Joe Biden on the for a good
reason because they don't want
impeachment to just just become this
this uh partisan tool where you just
automatically impeach whoever the
opposite the other guy is you know if
the other party is in power because that
would effectively turn the United States
into a parliamentary system rather than
the the current kind of Republican
Federal structure that we have
that'd be one reason and then the the
bad reason is just cowardice they just
don't they don't actually want that
fight because Republicans Republican
politicians are very often squishes and
and really their role in the American
political regime is as the junior
partner of the ruling class so their job
really is to lose and to lose with
dignity and but to not really get
anything done that's why on pretty much
every single issue the country has moved
radically to the left over the last
50 years abortion is one issue where
we've made some Headway going back but
even then not a ton even with the Dobbs
decision you're still gonna have
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
babies each year killed through abortion
so the
the all of the momentum has been toward
the left and some Republicans are
perfectly fine with that
maybe they're trying to throw it
I don't I'm not saying that's my view I
don't want to engage in conspiracy
theories
but
it's it's the simplest most convincing
explanation
that I can see
you're going a little bit woke you're
going a little bit woke they're not
really opposing the woke today you know
is woke Wednesday so on the member block
The Producers tell me that they they
have got a video
that is going to be impossible for me to
guess on woke Wednesday I am presented
with the woke videos that are going
viral and I have to either guess what
they're talking about or try to make
some sense of their argument and you
know specifically now white people are
the cause of all the problems in the
world white people I don't know white
people are probably causing the crisis
in Tibet for all we know they're just
the cause of all the problems in the
world and my producers are betting that
I cannot guess
what the white people are to blame for
now uh the show is starting now so if
you don't want to miss it head on over
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us we will see
you on the member block
[Music]
foreign